two former Prime Ministers are neck and
neck for the top job in Bulgaria
center right boyko borisov and Carol
petkov who leads an anti-corruption
coalition
voters hope a clear result will bring an
end to years of political crisis in the
European Union's poorest country
this is the only solution to the crisis
with this terrible war in Ukraine this
partition of the world we must very
clearly stay with the Democratic world
I voted for a normal European life I
voted for us to have a normal European
government normal European roads normal
European Healthcare normal European
education
both Front Runners are pro-western and
pro-ukraine though the NATO member has
been cautious with public support for
Kiev in the war
the Victor will also have to contend
with independent president rumin radhev
seen as Pro Kremlin
Russia's invasion of Ukraine deep into
Political crisis that has engulfed
Bulgaria since anti-corruption protests
in 2020.
after years of political deadlock people
are weary and want an end to instability
unseen since the fall of communism
people don't know what they want they're
being led on by false promises in the
end it doesn't work out there are no big
goals or Ambitions it's all tied to
various party lines they can do it
together they're just not willing to
they have other interests in mind
things are going to be difficult this
time as well I think no consensus will
be reached neither side will budge it
will be difficult to form a government
in the days before the vote a wave of
bomb threats targeted schools being used
as polling stations investigators blamed
hackers likely linked to Russia for
creating Panic to reduce voter turnout
and undermine this pivotal election
Bulgaria has long been among Europe's
top producers of ammunition even a main
supplier for Soviet Russia
a definitive result in Sunday's polls
and clear public support for Ukraine
could be pivotal for the key of
government ahead of a spring
counter-offensive